I've said this before,
but I really believe our show
has the greatest fans in the world.
Our fans are incredibly
funny and creative,
as they've demonstrated again
and again over the years.
That's why tonight I'm
very excited to announce
we are asking our fans to produce
an entire episode of our show
that we're calling Do It Yourself Conan.
(construction sounds)
It's the perfect project to help
get you through these pandemic times.
I mean, why waste time
learning another language
or how to paint or play the piano
or figure out a way to
stop global warming,
when you can spend your time
creating an episode of Conan?
Here's how Do It Yourself Conan will work.
We're gonna post a special
Conan episode online.
Your job is to pick one or more clips
from that episode and
recreate them from scratch.
The only rule: be creative.
Let your imaginations run wild.
We did this a few years
ago, it was a huge hit.
Here are just a few
examples from that show.
(upbeat music)
Really amazing.
In fact, I'm not sure why we never switch
to an all animated robots format.
I really don't know.
Just to whet your appetite,
one of the clips you'll get to recreate
is the now-famous moment
our associate producer
Jordan Schlansky said,
Then I prepared my body in various ways.
(laughter)
I cleaned it, I shaved it.
That's right.
Now you'll get the chance to recreate
Jordan Schlansky in various ways.
So again, have fun, be as
creative as you can be,
while of course following all
the current pandemic rules
for staying safe and healthy.
Then we'll take our favorite entries,
sew them together into
one incredible program
which will air during our
regular time slot in the Fall.
DIY Conan is being brought
to you by Snickers.
And thanks to our sponsor,
there are some incredible
prizes you can win including,
I'm sure it's just a
coincidence, probably,
a year's supply of Snickers!
(intense guitar music)
You didn't see that coming, did ya?
Cha-ching!
So go to teamcoco.com/diyconan
for all the details.